والمشهد في سوريا لا يتغير الا في تفاصيل
هذه المساحه عدد القتلى في عموم البلاد
ارتفع الى
3377 وعدد المصابين الى خمسه الاف ومئتين
وخمسه واربعين وحسب احصاءات الصحه السوريه
فقد ارتفع عدد القتلى في مناطق النظام الى
1347 وعدد المصابين الى 225
وقال الدفاع المدني السوري في تغريده على
تويتر اكثر من 90 ساعه منذ زلزال في شمال
سوريا والاف القتلى والجرحى لا زالوا تحت
الانقاض وقال ان الامور وصلت لنقطه حرجه
وتوقع ان يرتفع القتل بشكل حاد حيث لا
يمكن للاشخاص المحاصرين البقاء لفتره اطول
كما طالب بدعم دولي
قالت المتحدثه الاقليميه بسم اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر ايمان الطرابلسي
لعمل المنظمه يقتصر حتى الان على تقديم
جهود الاغاثه والمساعدات داخل المناطق
المنكوبه التابعه للنظام السوري لكنها
اكدت في مقابله مع الجزيره ان الصليب
الاحمر مستعد للمساعده في كل المناطق
السوريه
نحن حاليا موجودون في اللاذقيه وحلب وحما
وادلب وطرطوس هيئه اكبر عملياتنا للاغاثه
هي موجوده هناك ولكن فيما يخص بقيه
المناطق نحن رسالتنا هي واضحه نحن مستعدون
لتقديم الاستجابه والاغاثه الانسانيه في
كل المناطق مهما كان مهما كان انتماء
سكانها ومهما كان موقعها نحن منظمه هدفها
هي الاغاثه الانسانيه ورسالتنا هي واضحه
لكل الاطراف يجب ان تضع كل الاطراف مصلحه
الذات البشريه قبل كل الاحترازات السياسيه
وما وصفه بتخاذل الامم المتحده ومنظماتها
تجاهه الكارثه الكبرى التي حلت في شمال
غرب سوريا اكد ان طرق الوصول للشمال
السوري متاحه وغير متعطله ولا تنحصر في
طريق واحد وقال هيثم رحمه لامين العام
للائتلاف الوطني السوريين الموازيه لشمال
غرب سوريا هي افضل خيار الان لادخال
المساعدات
الدوليه مع ادخال المساعدات للمنطقه التي
تتعرض
لزلازل حتى هذه اللحظه وهي في المنطقه
التي فيها كلياتنا شمال سوريا والمهابر
الموازيه لنا هي افضل شيء ممكن المطارات
موجوده وايضا المخازن ارجو ان اكون واضح
معكم المخازن الامميه موجوده على الحدود
القريبه جدا ان الحدود
وبث الدفاع المدني السوري ومشاهد انقاذ
طفل من تحت الانقاض في منزل عائلته في
مدينه جنديرس بريف حلب امس الاربعاء
يا شباب
الحمد لله الحمد لله الحمد لله
[تصفيق]
غافه ضحايا الزلزال من السوريين تحديدا
بحكم ماساويه اوضاعهم قبل الزلزال اصلع
لكن واقع على استجابه لا يكافئ واتساع عن
نطاق المطالبات والحاجات الساعات الاخيره
بدات طلائع واغاثه تدخل الى سوريا من حمله
دشنا الهلال الاحمر القطري مكونه من خمس
شاحنات محمله بخمسه وثلاثين طنا من المواد
العاجله موالها صندوق قطر للتنميه ونقلت
عبر القوات الجويه الاميريه القطريه